We're going back to fluids,
my favourite! We're going to talk about
the drag equation.
This tells us the friction, or the air
resistance,
i.e the drag, acting on an object
which is moving through a fluid. Let's
say our sphere is moving that way, then
as it does as it moves through the air
the air pushes back
and it's going to create this frictional
air resistance drag
force and we actually have an equation
for what that is-
(Brady: The air being fluid by the way?
You keep)
(saying fluid but air is a fluid?)
- Air is a fluid! Right,
fluids are things that change
shape to fit the container that they are
inside.
So all gases, all liquids, even
some things
that you might think of solids
blend over into fluid. So yes, here we're
thinking air is definitely a fluid
for the purposes of fluid dynamics in
this particular equation.
So the equation says that the drag force
is equal
to one half times rho, where this
is the fluid density, multiplied by my
velocity
squared multiplied by the drag
coefficient
Cd - so this will depend on your object,
the shape of your object what it's made
from lots of things are going to affect
this.
Finally A which we call the
2D projected area. So you can think of
this
as the bit of your object that's kind of
like hitting
that wall of air.
- (Brady: The leading face?)
The leading face, yes.
So if you were - gonna test my artistic
talents - so if you're like a car
you've really got like the bonnet and then
kind of it kind of angles up and this
would be like your windscreen and then
like the roof,
and then you'd have your tyres
sticking out. So this is a car coming
towards you,
this area here is the frontal area
because this is what the air hits
as the car is coming towards you. So
imagine like, in all of these situations
the frontal area is as the object is
moving towards you what do you see?
And this is it, we just need to know
these values and this will give us
the drag force for a particular object.
Also it is important to say that
this will vary depending on the Reynolds
number,
which is something i've talked about
before. And what we tend to assume here
is that the flow is turbulent so that
means you're working here with a
Reynolds number of about
10 to the 4. That is true for
dropping a ball off a building, that is
true for a car driving;
it's turbulent flow, that's when this
equation is true. If you have
Laminar flow which is a bit more relaxed
chill you're going much more slowly
then it's a different equation. You get
what's called a linear drag equation, but
we're talking about
turbulent flow quadratic drag, this form.
So if I have my
sphere and i've got the air coming at it
like this then this has a Cd value of
0.47.
If we then compare that to say a cube
this has a drag coefficient
of 1.05; and then something else that
perhaps some of you picked up on is the
orientation here is going to be
important.
So if we change the cube and had it same
size,
put it on its side like this, and then
you have the air coming in.
It makes it more aerodynamic, the air is
going to hit and kind of pass around
that shape; so here the drag coefficient
goes down.
There's less drag because it's a more
streamlined shape.
- (Brady: Tom does the)
(material the object is made of make a)
(difference towards drag coefficient?)
Yes. It will in some contexts. I think
if you've got a sphere that's, let's say
made from metal versus made from
um lead, it's not really gonna have a big
effect because it's still the-
(Brady: But lead is a metal!)
- It's definitely having no
having no effect, okay.
If you've got like a steel sphere versus
let's say a concrete sphere it's still
smooth enough
that the change would hardly have an
effect. But if you had a
steel sphere versus, I don't know, a
sphere made of like candy floss
that's going to have an effect because
they're actually- there are like holes in
the candy floss; or if it's like made of
like a mesh,
there are holes and that's what's going
to have an effect. Or even- it's more the
the
smoothness of the surface. So like a golf
ball
is a sphere but has a lower drag
coefficient because it has the dimples
to make it more aerodynamic. So with the
angled cube,
just to sort of complete this, it
actually drops from 1.05 to 0.8.
And then the most streamlined thing, it's
literally called a streamlined body
or an aerofoil, this has a drag
coefficient of 0.04.
These things, this shape kind of comes
out of the the actual
computation and calculation of how do we
make this as small as possible.
So the air kind of comes in, it sort of
separates here and goes around
like so and then this tail kind of
causes it to come back together at the
end.
Rather than it breaking off and creating
all of this turbulence behind it that
adds to the drag,
so the fact that it can sort of stick
and come back together at the end
makes it really nice and streamlined. So
what we're going to do is we're going to
take
some well-known objects and we're going
to pretend that we are dropping them
through the air, or maybe in the ocean. So
race one,
uh we are doing falling objects through
the air.
(Brady: This is a drag race!)
- It's a drag race,
okay it's a drag race yeah we're doing a
drag race.
Imagine taking a human being and let's
say a bowling ball;
and we're going to drop both of these
out of a plane, something like a normal
skydive jump let's go with that.
So we're going to drop both of these
objects out of the plane and then the
drag equation
will tell you who will win the drag race,
like which object will hit the ground
first between the human
and the bowling ball if dropped
from a plane.
So we need to figure out these uh
parameters;
but before we do that we also need to
think about
what other forces are actually
present in this situation. So we've
talked about
drag, so if this is my bowling ball which
is falling
as this is coming down the page towards
the ground the drag force
is acting in that direction, it's pushing
it up.
The reason it's falling in the first
place is from gravity,
it's pulling it, gravitational
acceleration. So the force there
is mass times gravitational acceleration.
So you've got a force balance and this
will be the same for the human.
And so what's going to happen is when
you drop
your object, you're initially at zero so
we're going to start
start from rest that is important. So
we're starting from rest so we're
jumping out of a plane or dropping out
of a plane.
So we're starting at zero velocity. So at
the beginning
you're going to accelerate, gravity is
pulling you to the earth you're going to
speed up.
As you speed up velocity goes up, drag
looks like velocity squared. So as v goes
up drag
goes up. You're going to speed up more
and more from gravity and you're going
to
have more and more drag pushing against
you and eventually
they're going to be perfectly balanced.
You will not stop,
you will reach a constant speed.
(Brady: You won't just float in the air?)
That'd be great, wouldn't it?
So you accelerate most at the
beginning and your acceleration slows
down, but your speed is continually
increasing until it reaches a flat point
and that's called your terminal velocity.
Whichever one has the fastest
terminal velocity will win.
- (Brady: Unless you've)
(dropped from really really low)
Unless you drop from really low, yeah, no
you make a good point. Your your velocity
in general looks something like this;
this is time and this is going to be
v for velocity. And then you can see here,
so this would be your terminal velocity
your maximum vt.
So what you see is you you increase faster
faster and then you slow down slow
down slow down slow down slow down slow
down
and then you'd never get- so this is the
shape that you get and you can solve the
equations and get this exact shape. So we
actually know the-
these the time it takes to reach your
terminal velocity on a skydive, because
lots of people do it!
So after three seconds you're about 50%
of the way there,
after eight seconds you're about 90%
of the way and after 15 seconds you're
about 99%.
It's tending towards this as time goes
to infinity, so you're probably never
going to exactly reach the terminal
velocity but
you're going to get so close that we can
say you are. We're assuming here,
we're reaching it and that's going to be
our speed and that's going to determine
who wins the race.
So to actually get the equation then
we've got to solve
drag force equals gravity. So we want to
know when these are equal,
we know the formula for drag force, so we
just say that's a half
rho v squared Cd
A equals mg; and this is what we're
interested in,
right, the velocity is what we care about
so you rearrange this
and we're going to get: v equals
2 mg, now I've got to divide by the rho,
the drag coefficient the area and
then I've got a square root.
And we take the positive square root
because, well we're falling down, but
we have a- we're taking the positive
value of velocity. So this is going to be
our terminal velocity
here. So in order to figure this out for
our human
and for our bowling ball we need to know
these values.
And we just plug them in and whichever
one has the highest terminal velocity
is going to win our race. What's your-
what's your money on?
Human versus bowling ball?
- (Brady: I think the)
(bowling ball is going to hit the ground
first.)
Okay, all right, yeah, well we'll see we'll
see. It's kind of like it's-
obviously the human's heavier but yeah
there's something else going on I think-
(Brady: There's more area, it feels
like more area.)
(And not quite dense enough for its mass)
(to overtake- well we'll see.)
- Yeah yeah,
(I'm not totally confident.)
- Okay, all right,
so so we're going for
we think it might be the bowling ball.
(How's the human falling?)
- Yeah, like star
jumping let's say kind of
(sort of pancaking? They're not, they're)
(not going head first?)
- Not going head
first yeah, no
that is important.
- (So you're almost)
(giving your maximum amount of area you
could?)
Yes yes you're not like going head first
and trying to go really fast yeah,
Which would be terrifying. We need to just
know all of these values now: 2 doesn't
change,
gravity - so I'll write that over here
because that's not going to change,
that's 9.81 meters per second squared,
gravitational acceleration on Earth. The
mass m,
that matters so m. A human
um 100kg ish?
(That's heavy but yeah but it's around-)
It's a nice number yeah, we like nice
numbers, we're going 100kg.
A bowling ball I think around like 5 kg?
They're about eight and a half pounds I
think so 5kg.
Then we've got the air density, so that
doesn't change
because we're falling through air. It's a
bit of an approximation, we're going to
just take it to be constant.
Right so 1.225
kilograms per metre cubed is sort of
average air density I think at 15
degrees at like sea level.
So obviously when you're a bit higher
up it's a bit thinner; it's the same for
both of them as well so it doesn't
really matter too much does it? Now the
interesting ones: we've got the drag
coefficient,
and then we've got the area. So the
bowling ball,
it's a sphere, we already said what the
drag coefficient of a sphere was, it's 0.47.
So even though it has a couple of holes
for your hands they're not going to have
that big of an effect so it's about 0.47.
And it is nice and smooth as well,
so that's- maybe maybe the super smooth
it's really well polished maybe that
overcomes the little holes for your
fingers.
Now for a human; so this value this
will depend
on the human, right, because you can have
somebody who's really really skinny
is possibly going to be more aerodynamic
than
someone who is more round.
- (Brady: Doesn't the)
(area take care of that though?)
Yes but it's also going to have an
effect on the drag coefficient
as well. So the area, yeah the area
is obviously gonna-
- (And you could be)
(hairy and not hairy..)
- Exactly, very good, yeah
hairy and not hairy
etc. So so this is about
between 1 and 1.3.
So you can- you know, various experiments
have been done on humans it's somewhere
between 1 and 1.3.
Now the area; so bowling ball
it's a sphere, as it's coming towards you
it's 2d
projected area will be a circle, you're
seeing a circle. It's quite-
potentially hard to visualise but it
would be a circle, it's like the
projection of the sphere into 2d
is going to be a circle. So it's-
- (It's not)
(that hard to visualise, you've drawn one
there!)
Right so so the area then is is going
to be pi times the radius squared;
I think the radius for a bowling ball is
about radius I think is 11 centimeters
for a standard
so the area is going to be 0.036
metres squared. It's quite a small area.
The area
for a human,
this is going to vary quite a bit
depending on the size of your human.
I did some rough calculations
and said well using nice numbers about
two meters tall,
about like half a metre wide, it's kind
of like
one metre squared - about. Ranging from
less as well.
- (That's a big human, but yeah.)
It's a big human so I think I think I
went for like 0.5
to 1 metre squared I think here.
That was you know there's enough of a
range in there,
I think I actually used 1 in the
calculation so it's a reasonably big
human,
feel free to obviously import your own
numbers, maybe measure yourself and find
out what your
frontal area is and plug it into the
formula, see how fast you would be. So
now we've actually got everything and we
can get
the terminal velocity, so this is the big
moment, whichever one of these is bigger
is going to win our race.
So the human, you get around 37
metres per second which is pretty fast.
That is
really fast, you're moving 37 metres
every second when you fall at terminal
velocity through the air. Now the bowling
ball! So this is what your money was on
wasn't it?
So the bowling ball, the velocity here is
about
69 metres per second.
- (Boom!)
Boom! I know. So it's actually
wins by quite a long way.
You had the right idea when we were
chatting about this, right? The the
bowling ball
is a lot smaller, so it has a much lower
mass,
so its velocity is less because m is
going down. These two on the bottom
are much smaller as well, the drag and the
area is so much smaller for the bowling
ball
compared to the human it really wins out.
So it would be almost
twice as fast, I think
if we did an average skydive - somewhere
between 10 and 14 000 feet - I think I did
to get a nice average number, um you can
calculate this
so time to fall I think I did 4 000
metres,
13 000 feet or so. For the human this
would take about 108
seconds whereas the bowling ball would
take 58 seconds. So just under a minute,
the bowling ball hits the ground,
whereas the
human you're going like 1 minute 40, 1
minute 50. So
bowling ball wins quite a long way
actually.
- (Brady: Have you ever been skydiving?)
I haven't. I'd be up for it!
- (You seem like)
(someone who would have done it!)
I've done a bungee jump, and this kind of
put me off. I always wanted to do a
bungee jump and then
the- I was, I got to the top and the guy
was like right you're gonna go I was
like okay fine straight away
and that that moment I don't think I
could describe,
it just felt so wrong. I'm facing the
ground, you don't feel like you're
attached.
And so it kind of scared me that if I
jumped out of a plane
I'd have the exact same like urgh-
- (I think a plane's)
(so much higher though it doesn't seem)
(real?)
- That's the other thing, because yeah
because with the bungee you can see the
ground; the plane you're just kind of
like I'm floating this is great and then-
(Anyway I haven't done it either so)
So now we're going to look at a second
example, we're going to compare
much bigger objects and imagine dropping
them overboard from a ship
and allowing them to sink to the bottom
of the ocean. Because you've got the same
forces; you've got gravity pulling them
down
to the depth of the ocean, and you've got
the drag force pushing up.
So it's in a slightly different fluid so
some of our parameters will change
but it means we can sort of pretend to
do this with larger objects.
So we're going to consider the Eiffel
tower; versus the Empire State Building;
versus a wrecking ball.
- (Brady: Orientations and)
(where we're dropping them)
- So if we have
the Eiffel tower,
this is where you're measuring the drag.
The Eiffel tower is kind of falling down
like this,
turn on its side and let it drop like
that.
- (And that's because you've got all)
(the drag coefficients?)
- Exactly that's because
to be able to do these calculations you
need this drag coefficient and for the
Eiffel tower in the Empire State
Building we actually have estimates of
the values
based on wind blowing into them, so
that's what we need
for that particular sideways angle.
(All right, oh, so what's going to win?)
Yeah so this time you've got like the,
the very big heavy
box-like Empire State, like lots of
concrete and metal;
you've got the Eiffel tower which is a
little bit smaller
but obviously still quite tall, still
quite heavy-
- (Are we taking its sort of)
(holeyness into account? All the
mesh of it?)
Yeah yeah exactly, I was about to
say - that's the
key with the Eiffel tower it's-
the Empire State is just like glass and
concrete and metal, the Eiffel tower's
got lots of holes.
And then you've got, just just to throw
it into the mix, you've got
just a big like
concrete wrecking ball.
- (Brady: I reckon the)
(wrecking ball first-)
All right so is that based on the
bowling ball having won last time? You
think there's something about the sphere?
(Just the- my intuition is it would)
(just plunge quickly.)
- Yeah
(And then I think- although the one thing)
(you're not taking into account; when)
(things sink)
(I imagine like doing that, but these)
(aren't going to do
that are they? They're)
(just going to push straight down?)
- Yeah,
yeah they're all heavy enough that
there's not- yeh they're going to just
drop,
they are going to just drop.
(In that case the Empire State Building.)
All right so you think wrecking ball
first?
- (Wrecking ball, Empire State but-)
(the Empire State Building might beat the)
(wrecking ball actually...)
(And I reckon the Eiffel tower last.)
- All right.
(For some reason.)
- Okay
So it's the same idea, we need to just
know what is our terminal velocity
and whichever ones have the highest
value that is going to win
our race. So now we're moving in water, so
in the ocean.
Gravity of course doesn't change, 9.81
metres per second squared.
Now the density does change. So we're
going to do this
at the, uh, let's do it at the Marianas
Trench- Mariana trench.
The the deepest point in the ocean at
11000 metres. So
the average density of the pacific ocean
is 1036 kilograms
per metre cubed. So we've got uh gravity
doesn't change,
the density is fixed for all of them
1036 kilograms, so obviously
because we've changed fluid that's the
key thing that's changed here
compared to the first time; the density
here is like a thousand times bigger
than what we had in air. But everything
else is is still dependent on the object.
(Brady: So that's doing its work
on the bottom)
(half of the equation? Okay.)
Exactly. So these are going to be much
slower because the number on the bottom
is now much much bigger. It makes sense,
you would expect to fall faster through
air than you would through water. If you
jump into a pool you don't sink as fast
as if you jump out of a plane.
So the objects then, so we've got the
the wrecking ball just a nice big sphere.
We've got the Eiffel tower with lots of
holes
in it, and then the Empire State Building;
so for these three objects
we again need to know mass, drag
coefficient,
area. So a wrecking ball, average size
wrecking ball
2250 kilograms - they're heavy. The
Eiffel tower weighs about nine million
kilograms, perhaps unsurprisingly is
pretty heavy. The Empire State though
is going to be even heavier, it's
365 million
kg. So some very big objects, these two
are much much bigger. Drag coefficient,
we've got still a sphere; the Eiffel
tower, so
this is estimated to be between 1.8
and 2. The holeyness and the fact that it
has this steel frame
actually creates a lot of drag because
as the wind hits it
it kind of- some bits go through and it
just creates lots of turbulence and
that's actually not-
(Or as the water goes through it?)
- As the
water rather than the air, like yeah. So
the Empire State is
a bit better so that's about 1.3 to 1.5.
So definitely the most streamlined is
indeed the wrecking ball, as we might
have thought, but the Empire State is
more streamlined than the Eiffel tower.
Now the area:
for a wrecking ball again it's a sphere,
so it's going to project into a circle,
so if you plug in these are about just
under half a metre
uh in radius, about a metre across - I've
got it as 0.67
metres squared is going to be your pi
times the radius squared. The area for
the Eiffel tower, so you can
think of it as a triangle, kind of do
half base times height; but then there's
loads of holes.
I've got a value here of about 750
metres squared. And then the empire state
building, much less holes,
it's just a big old block of glass and
concrete. So I've got that
estimated about 28000 metres squared. So
there's a really big difference.
Now, plugging in the numbers, this is the
this is the moment.
- (Brady: This is interesting because)
(I see the mass is going to go on the top)
(of the equation so the mass is going to)
(get things moving but-)
- The mass has a
really big effect, yeh.
(But how big an effect?)
- But then it's also
going to be slowed down by,
by this one being very big on the bottom.
Which one did you- should we go with
which one you said was gonna-
(Let's go let's go with the
Eiffel tower first.)
The Eiffel tower first, all right. So the
Eiffel tower;
plugging in all of these numbers uh this
terminal velocity
comes out about 11 metres per second.
It doesn't mean much at this point,
it's just a
it's a number. What we care about is
where the other two fit. So you've said
that you thought this was gonna be the
slowest? Okay so we thought that was
gonna be the slowest and the wrecking
ball was going to win?
So let's go with that one next
because if this isn't faster
then you've just-
So the wrecking ball then, you plug
in the numbers for that
and you get 12, about 12 metres a second.
(Brady: Wow it's really close!)
Really really close,
yeah. And it's it's because
it's because of that mass, because
there's such a big difference,
the mass on the top there, it's it's so
much times bigger it's 9 million
compared to 2000.
- (So you need more mass)
(to push through that water)
Yeah yeah. So even though the area is
obviously so much smaller of this
the wrecking ball, the
Eiffel tower's isn't
quite big enough to really slow it down
too much.
(All right go on then, put me out of my
misery)
No you do- you're actually winning
so far!
As long as this one is somewhere
between 11 and 12.
- (I'll see what might)
(happen though.)
So the Empire State is
13 metres per second. It's actually the
fastest.
It's the biggest, it's the heaviest,
so yes it
makes sense it would go the fastest.
But we've seen that the Eiffel tower is
bigger and heavier than a wrecking ball
and goes slower.
So there really is a lot it's a-
it's really to do with the drag
coefficient and the area. For me the
interesting thing about
drag equation, terminal velocity, this
whole thing; is just how important
how aerodynamic your object is and how
streamlined and that actual
frontal area, that projected area; making
that as small as possible,
making everything nice and pointy is
going to make you go so much faster
compared to being really heavy.
- (Brady: So when)
(you hear all these much)
(loved and hackneyed stories about)
(dropping ball bearings and bowling balls)
(off the)
(leaning tower of Pisa and they should)
(hit at the same time, you must be like go
away!)
(You're not even thinking about drag.)
- Well
that's the point, yeah. So
because the air on the Earth is
sufficiently thick
it has an effect. So there's a really
nice um
experiment that NASA - there's actually a
NASA video of this
on the moon of one of the astronauts-
(Brady: Dave Scott.)
Oh you-
- (My favourite- my favourite astronaut.)
Dropping the feather and the hammer?
(Falcon feather)
- Yeah yeah yeah yeah the
video is awesome isn't it?
[Dave Scott: Well in my left hand
I have a feather,
and my right hand a hammer...]
- So he drops
the hammer and the feather
and they hit the ground at the same time.
[and I'll drop the two of them here and]
[hopefully]
[they'll hit the ground at the same time.]
[How about that!]
- Obviously that's because the
air is so much thinner that drag
doesn't have-
(There's no air)
- Well. So the drag just
doesn't have that effect
whereas on Earth you do have- drag does
have an effect so
if you did that on Earth it's not going
to happen, right? The hammer's obviously
going to beat the feather because
there's more drag on the feather.
(Brady: So density, because
the density of the)
(air on the moon is zero)
(means you've got you've got a zero on)
(the bottom of your equation.)
(Does that mean it's going to-)
- So the
terminal velocity will just be really big.
So you'll just keep accelerating. Yeah if
your density is
really really small or is in fact zero
this formula says my terminal velocity
will keep
increasing.
- (Regardless of mass?)
Yeah if it's zero completely
regardless of mass
yeah because because what you're going
to do, instead of flattening off this
would just continue to increase.
This episode has been brought to you by
Brilliant. In-depth interactive courses
like these ones,
well that's Brilliant's bread and butter.
But I have to admit I'm also a little
bit partial
to these daily challenges, have a look at
some of these:
one to five...
Stylish socks, they are kind of stylish.
And a mystery of dice.
To check these out in more detail, plus
everything else on the site,
go to brilliant.org/numberphile.
Have a look, it's elegantly designed,
educational and frankly
it's kind of fun too. There's the address
again,
brilliant.org/numberphile. By the way
there's 20%
off a premium subscription, unlocking
everything on the site,
if you use that /numberphile.
[Extras] This is this is the power of the
Reynolds number really.
- (Brady: Does the Reynolds)
(number itself have units then?)
The Reynolds number does not have units.
The Reynolds number is just a number.
And we can actually see that; so the
Reynolds number itself
is density times length times speed
divided by viscosity...